اهلا بكم هذا المبنى هو اول مقر للجمعيه
الوطنيه الكبرى في تركيا او البرلمان شيد
عام 1915 هنا في انقره في ميدان ايليس
تحديدا يتميز هذا المبنى كونه من اكثر
المباني تميزا في البلاد لانه صمم على
الطراز المعماري التركي بنقوش وزخارف
مستوحى من العماره الاسلاميه هذه الهيئه
الوحيده كانت تتمتع بصلاحات بالصلاحيات
التشريعيه بموجب الدستور التركي والتي
تاسست في انقره عام ثلاثه عام 1920 للثلا
من ابريل في خضم حرب الاستقلال المبنى
واصل ليصبح مقر لحزب الشعب الجمهوري وهو
الحزب الذي اسس تركيا الحديثه العلمانيه
والغي الخلافه العثمانيه طبعا باوامر من
مصطفى كمال باشا المعروف باتاتورك والتي
تعني ابو الاتراك واتى تركن اول رئيس لهذا
الحزب وهو اليوم الحزب المعارض لاردوغان
منذ العام 2010 ويتراسه
زعيم المعارضه التركيه والتي انتقل الان
في الانتخابات الى الجوله الثانيه مع
منافسه اردوغان